for lunch and we have our two next
speakers already admitted to the
participant section and I want to
introduce Wendy hunt who is the
executive director of the greater
Merrimack so he can Valley Chamber of
Commerce and current chair of the group
of executives and Tracy Hutchins who is
executive director of my Upper Valley
Business Alliance which is a result of
the merging of Lebanon plus others plus
Hanover plus others and asked and who
was is the prior president of that group
and I'd like them to talk to us about
what they see as permanent damage or on
ability of some of the businesses to
reopen how what what they are going
through in order to reopen and what the
prospects look like for coming back to
full business status in the next 3-4
months or more
next year so I'd like to welcome Wendy
hunt and and Tracy Hutchins to talk
Thank You Tracy do you want to go ahead
and start sure I'd be happy to
hi everyone and thank you for having us
today
so here in the Upper Valley we've been
very fortunate I know one of the
questions when Susan asked me to appear
today was how many businesses have we
had that will close permanently that we
know of so far and I think we've
actually been four
that we have not had many we've had to
businesses and Hanover closed
permanently due to the köppen 19
situation and we've had a few businesses
in Lebanon also closed although none of
them were related to the köppen 19
situation two of our major retailers pr1
and JC Penney's are closing and and
those are due to you know forces in the
in the major retail world and then we've
had a small diner that closed due to
personal reasons that was just prior to
the köppen situation
however I am concerned that we've had we
will have businesses that will close
soon in in the next few months and my
concern is due to the fact that right
now our businesses many have applied for
the PPP funds or the idle loans through
the SBA and they have received those
monies but you know it nowhere near
replaces the funds that they have lost
in revenue over the last couple of
months during this situation so I'm I am
concerned that from talking to our
businesses that you know although
they've received those funds some of
them are really hanging on by their
fingernails and and even as we're
starting to reopen you know it's still
not easy you know restaurants are able
to reopen now for outdoor dining however
I think that is more of a benefit to our
restaurants that tend to be smaller in
scale where you know they can have the
outdoor space and have almost as many
tables as they had functioning indoors
as normal but we have some of larger
restaurants for instance in Hanover
Mali's and Jesse's which is owned by the
blue sky
Restaurant Group which chose not to
reopen because their their very large
establishments the costs for them to
reopen are huge I was told around
$100,000 just to buy enough food to be
able to support their typical menu and
there's just not no way for them to have
enough outdoor seating to be able to
accommodate for that like they would in
their their regular operations some of
our our smaller businesses are still
struggling there's a lot of even though
they're all following the guidelines put
out by the New Hampshire Department of
Public Health and and the Gopher
committee there's a lot of inconsistency
with those guidelines and and so they're
they're struggling with that a bit Wendy
would you want to chime in um thank you
for having me as Susan said I'm the
president of the Greater Merrimack so he
can Valley Chamber of Commerce and I
also in the current board chair of the
New Hampshire Association to chamber
commerce executives and so it's with
both those hats I'm gonna be talking to
you today I my chamber covers the twelve
towns of the Merrimack and so he can
Valley region also in neck to Nashua and
Merrimack and beyond you know we have a
lot of businesses that have yet to open
I worry as a chamber person about you
know a few things one what are the
habits of shoppers gonna be now that
businesses are reopening i I don't think
from 90 days ago we can expect this to
jump right into business as usual also
at the end of July when the extra $600
that is are part of people's
unemployment checks coming to an end
unless Congress extends it people are
going to be short on cash so I do worry
about having enough customers I worry
about any regulation or any further
specifically I would say the business
profits
or the business enterprise tax as you
all know any business who makes over
50000 gross is going to be expected to
report and I know last year that the
legislature had an agreement with the
governor that the business profits taxes
and the beatty would not be raised
beyond 2019 rates so I do ask you to
keep that in mind as you consider you
know the state revenues which I know are
going to be down as a result of this but
I do worry about any further burden on
our businesses I think we're not going
to know for many months to come how our
do you have any idea about what's going
on with your your restaurant situation
or any of your manufacturing any of the
bigger bound fixtures in your area
because Hittner and Aileen and some of
the air Mar have been able to pivot
they're doing all right on this in our
region restaurants it's been slow I mean
they they've really tried to accommodate
outdoor seating
obviously it's weather dependent their
capacity I'll give an example I went to
Hampshire Hills outdoors the other night
when it opened it's one of my members
and the tables are definitely spaced
apart and I counted maybe in the whole
evening maybe 50 dinars which you know
normally they would typically do about
200 the owners were actually working it
and have not brought back their staff
their staff as for restaurants in the
northern part I don't know how they
fared this past weekend I would like to
that information myself I know that from
a meeting with Taylor causal this
morning that our tolls were down 40
percent from a typical Memorial Day
weekend which indicates to me that
obviously there were not people spending
money in the in the state you know we
have warmer weather down here in Amherst
as compared to up in Littleton or Conway
so I would hope that the governor at
some point is going to open the you know
the indoor parks a restaurant
I'll give you an example I was just down
in Florida on my home state visiting my
parents and the restaurants opened a
week ago for the outdoors but they can
also now have fifty percent capacity
indoors which was like every other table
and I think that was actually a good
good model because you didn't have
people on top of each other they were
also having you you know use hand
sanitizer and wear a mask to your table
I think unless we can step it up with
our restaurants and give them some more
capacity I don't know it's already a
tough business for most of them right
and and I would chime in the our lodging
industry has been hit very very hard by
this situation you know in in our region
we have several hotels right now they're
allowed to take in people looking for
rooms for essential personnel one of our
hotels in Lebanon has has been doing
okay with that however they've let
almost all of their staff go there's
only around five of them that are you
know which is the upper management that
are doing everything from cleaning the
rooms to taken in the reservations to do
in the maintenance we have several other
hotels in the area that are not open or
are very very minimal and I think you
know that going forward I know I have
people who call our office from out of
state and are looking for rooms but I
don't I don't see them coming back as
quickly you know I don't think that
people are going to flood to the state
and people will be looking to take
vacations or hotel rooms like they were
before and I think our hotels are going
to really suffer and you know hotel
capacity is a very funny thing anyways
if if hotel runs at 65% capacity they're
considered successful and you know our
hotels in the Upper Valley typically run
much higher so I think across the state
we're going to see hotels have enough
another concern that I'm seeing in our
area and hearing from landlords is gonna
have to do with not only residential
tenants but commercial tenants once the
governor you know enacted the the
executive order of you know to stop stop
foreclosures and conviction processes
etc that has really put a lot of our
business owners that you know have
apartment buildings or even even even
somebody with a two or three family if
they're not receiving the income from
that I'm hoping some of the Gopher
dollars are going to come to that
because also the businesses even though
they're supposed to be paying you know
twenty five percent of their PPP to rent
it's not covering a lot of the expenses
so there's also concern what might
happen to the real estate market if
there isn't some sort of relief for the
land not the landowners the landlord's
and that will also trickle down to the
municipalities I know here in Lebanon or
rather West Lebanon the tenants of our
powerhouse mall have used force majeure
to not pay their rents to the mall and
that is something like a $22,000 per
month towards the city of Lebanon for
tax purposes so the city of Lebanon has
been meeting with business owners to
discuss implementing some sort of
payment plan for taxes because they're
expecting that there's going to be
several businesses that will not be able
to pay their property taxes also
interesting I'm not sure who else lives
in the southern part but as the malls
have opened down here a lot of the
stores continue to be closed at the
outlet mall over on route 3 in Merrimack
it's you know I would say a third of the
can we answer any questions for you oh
yes we have three questions already
representative of Rami I was going to
follow up on that calm about retail I'm
more could be concerned like you do
about retail coming back because you
know my observation is even once they
opened it up that not a traffic is not
there that's for stores I don't see
people going back to the anyway I know
and about five stores just vacant and
then obviously this close they have the
anchor stores that are closing and and
you know how many people are going to
continue buying via online versus going
to the brick-and-mortar well you bring
up a great point I've definitely seen a
lot more Amazon Prime trucks in the area
in the last three months and that goes
back to people's personal shopping
habits and I think as chambers we've
done a pretty good job of getting the
message out to our communities and let
me just step back for a minute there are
about 50 chambers in the state of New
Hampshire and we have been in constant
communication with one another under the
Association umbrella and this has been a
really a huge topic of ours we've done a
really good job with really trying to
present to our communities I hope we've
done a good job presenting to our
communities without strong business
community we don't strong communities
these these are the people that your
high schooler goes to to get a donation
you're attracting your boy scouts your
church you name it so I think we really
have to press upon and maybe that's
something you all can help with with
some type of advertising dollars of
unless you shop locally you know Amazon
is not going to be the one you know
supporting our communities it's
convenient but they're not going to
support them but but I agree with you
that it scares me in the three months
that people have been home that they'll
they're willing to go to Home Depot and
Walmart and yet I haven't seen them in
the boutique's yet right and and we're
hearing the same thing from our small
retailers is you know if you're a small
boutique and you sell clothing you know
you have if you're going to buy
something you want to try it on well who
wants to go into a fitting room right
now you know there there's concerns over
yet you know just some people are not
willing to go out yet or spend time
shopping and and you know in the state
really hasn't been saying even though
businesses are open we still have a stay
at home order in place so there really
isn't an encouragement to do that you
know people are not sure whether to you
know do they wear face masks do they not
wear a face mask obviously we all should
be wearing face masks not everyone
agrees and and so therefore you know
I've heard from some of our businesses
that their employees are concerned about
working are they going to be exposed so
there there's a lot of concerns and I
and I don't think consumer confidence is
there yet to go out and support the
businesses you know some of our
restaurants have done okay with takeout
and people have stepped up to support
restaurants in that way but that's
that's a fairly easy ask you know you
drive you drive over you pick up your
food you take at home going out to spend
time in a in a small retail store to do
the kind of shopping that some of these
retailers need to survive it's not
happening yet well I keep in mind
we don't know what the fallouts gonna be
months from now with people's incomes I
mean are you more apt to stay at home
and cook after you've been to Walmart
then to go out into a restaurant or a
retail shop or whatever because you
don't know what your incomes gonna look
like and already a lot of people taking
a huge hit so that worries me in the
recovery that people aren't gonna have
the money to spend
right and in some of our businesses so
you know Walmart is still doing fine you
know it sells the necessities that you
need it sells groceries but furniture
stores are not doing well you know
people are not planning for those larger
purposes the auto dealers are really on
life support at this point and for some
of them you know they have purchased
they have contracts with their
franchises and they have to purchase so
many autos or their find you know so so
the cars keep coming and they're being
delivered but they're not being sold and
if you drive around and you look at some
of these auto dealers you see full lots
and and if you were to go in you'll find
one or two people because for the most
part they've let their staff go the
other industry that's hurting I wouldn't
call an industry sector would be the
consultants the people that would come
into your home and fix your computer or
I mean we have so many members that are
sole proprietors that do this type of
business you know recreating websites
Traci help me with consultants I'm
drawing a blank I'm sorry but I list but
you know any anybody that would come
into your home unless it's an emergency
like a plumber you know you're probably
not gonna have them come in your home so
those businesses are definitely I'm
hurting right right any of your your
small trades some what some of our
builders are doing okay I have a
gentleman who has a roofing business and
and he's actually not seen a lot of
downturn but like Wendy mentioned anyone
that would go into the home norm
your plumbers your electricians unless
you have something that's dire people
are putting that off either either they
don't have the income to pay these
professionals or you know or if it's
something that they can put off and and
they're doing so so those people are
seeing a loss of income as well since
then we can't hear you I'm sorry because
he unmuted you muted me when my phone
went off again
I wish I could mute the phone yeah when
I've I've had a couple of urgent
problems that had to be resolved with a
home visit it took quite a while to
convince people to come and do the home
visit because they are afraid as well of
contracting a virus that fear may be
stronger in the Upper Valley because we
had had the first breakout in New
Hampshire of of the illness and since
that time people have been a lot more
willing to to sequester themselves but
we've got three hands up now I'm lips
Tommy yes this is Chris I think Tucker
may have been raised in with a question
that you just want to check with her as
well okay um well you know you can't you
can't raise your hand I'll take you
first here in the North Country
lots of people are not happy to see
people from other parts of the state or
you are from Massachusetts particularly
they're very if we've only had five
cases and cause and people want people
to quarantine for two weeks if they come
to their summer home before they go out
shopping and doing things and they're
not happy to see them in store
they are afraid that we'll get infected
if we attract the tourists that we
ordinarily do I've had quite a
conversation by email with our local
Chamber of Commerce about maybe the
state should put up signs saying wear a
mask always outside in stores but these
actually are rules they're guidelines
and the quarantining for two weeks seems
difficult to achieve you want a tourist
economy that people would come up and
rent a cottage or stay at the family
camp stay home for two weeks before they
went anywhere so is this true in other
parts of the state that we have
represented you find that the local
population is dubious about trying to
resume the same activities as in the
past well I'll start because I'm right
on the border I will tell you that
despite all efforts to keep people from
Massachusetts etc as the governor says
out I decided to venture out this
weekend myself on to 101a down towards
Nashua and I thought oh I'll go to home
goods or something like that the parking
lots were full of Massachusetts cars the
lines were around the building and eat
in every single place I try to go to I
would just say personally I think it's
just unrealistic to try to keep people
out we do have the you know US
Constitution in the Commerce Clause and
what I just hope recommend to people is
wear your masks wash your hands stay
safely away from people because I at the
risk of using the words a new normal
which I cannot stand it is kind of the
new normal and I I just think it's
unrealistic to I understand their point
especially if you're you know immune
system is compromised I would be very
nervous
but but you know I he that I think
definitely people have that feeling
across the state but I think it's maybe
a pretty loud minority too because I
think most people are realistic that
some point we got to open up we see that
as well in the Upper Valley and I have
had people say to me you know there's
there's numerous people from out of
state that own second homes in this area
around Moscow Millay Cup in Orford and
and I have heard that same sentiment as
well I I do think however you know we I
think the second largest industry in New
Hampshire is tourism and and I'm hoping
though that we will be able to open back
up and allow those people at some point
because those are important dollars for
our state and they do keep a lot of our
businesses going in the summer pan
overseas something like 5,000 visitors
that come to Dartmouth College
throughout the summer and you know and
even though most of the students are
gone in the summertime that traffic
keeps our downtown businesses going so I
I do hope at some point we can allow
those people those visitors to come back
so do you think we ought to be offering
that visitors free masks and not just
the businesses well I'm not sure if the
well the state is just the governor
announced last Friday that we're not
offering free mass for the businesses
any longer they have two liquor store I
I think you know at this point if if
someone hasn't gone out and purchased
themselves a cloth mass then there's
somebody who is not going to wear a mask
regardless so I don't know about
offering out of visitors mass but I I do
hope at some point we can have them come
back yes thank you I live in the Upper
Valley in the summer and no Hanna
Burwell right now
it's kind of a ghost town but I'm
concerned that so many businesses count
on the large crowds in the summer long
lines sold out restaurants and all that
it's very hard for me to picture this
some are getting enough business for
some of those restaurants to survive my
other thing that hasn't been mentioned
by anyone right now Dartmouth coach
isn't running my bus company C&J
Trailways there's no buses
so obviously this has got to be part of
the picture too yes and and there's some
areas of the state that do rely heavily
on bus traffic for visitors throughout
the state our area sees numerous buses
come through as well and I think that is
going to be a concern the other thing to
remember particularly with the
restaurants is right now it's all
weather dependent yes they can put tents
up
but those tents are not allowed to have
sides on them so if if we get a a hard
summer rainstorm anyone who is sitting
there is very likely going to get wet as
they try to eat their food so you know
it's it's all very very weather
dependent and and that's certainly going
to affect our restaurants and your right
hand over which is usually a very
difficult place to find a parking space
is very easy right now to find parking
spaces it is it is very much a ghost
town I could also comment on you were
talking about summer crowds I asked this
exact question this morning of Taylor as
well we have a weekly call with him as
Chamber of Commerce leaders and my
question was exactly that because so
many businesses including ours all the
Chamber's have you know events planned
that keep our budgets afloat and most
haven't been canceled so my question to
him was you know in these outdoor events
you know would we be able to have more
than 10 people and he said to look to
the guidelines of like the racetracks
you know where you could have
you know a group of 10 people you know
like just like if they were your friends
and then space it out six weeks six feet
have another group of ten you know that
people that knew each other so sometimes
this would be groups of four groups of
six groups of ten and that we would be
able to have more than ten people so in
the lines that I'm seeing I know exactly
you're talking about like lining up for
ice cream or you know fried clams they
are doing a pretty good job of putting
tape down and and you know just keeping
people six feet apart you know but
you're right is that realistic for
hundreds of people lining up probably
not
speaking of tourism one of the things I
would ask you to consider also as I know
state revenues are going to be down
significantly but since we are going to
need tourism and tourism to come back to
support so many of our businesses not
just restaurants and lodging but you
know those people come and they they
shop in the retail stores and they help
support you know numerous trades people
with you know summer homes and work on
that is to consider not cutting the
travel and tourism budget I know it's
it's probably under consideration but I
hope that if you do cut it it won't be
too major too deep of a cut because
we're certainly going to need that but
advertising to get people to back to the
state when we're able to reel them can I
ask a question I'm if you all I'm
hearing a particular date that lodging
might open I don't know about you Tracy
I'm here in June 8th is anyone else
hearing that lodging might possibly
reopen June 8th doesn't look like it we
only have one member that is on these
Commission's and he's new he's new to
the committee and couldn't come
because he's in the opening commission
god but we could try and ask him uh
we've got another question from
representative Schamberg ever since
Chandler he's so muted I keep pushing on
you'd hear how about now you're okay
okay Thank You Tracy and Wendy for
appearing today Wendy basically you
mentioned something about your comment
about tax rates do you have any
statistics from a reliable source that
show of a reduction in the BPT tax rates
proposed by the governor would have a
positive impact on state revenue for
state services I wasn't talking about a
reduction in taxes I was just talking
about you know just in general that I
would worry if taxes were increased from
the 2019 2020 levels i I didn't I'm not
saying either way reduction I was just
concerned if they were raised thank you
I actually had not heard that he was
proposing to reduce them but I'm not
gonna look like you guys are we have
trouble reading the tea leaves about
these things the problem we can't print
money and we do provide everybody
essential services and if we don't
provide them the property taxes are
going up so and representative Malloy
was next I I want to back up to the
advertising budget and marketing for the
state of New Hampshire I how much is in
that wine how much do we how much do we
spend and where do we spend it
because if if that is of a concern to
chambers and businesses in this state
then we probably should be taught not us
but somebody should be talking about how
to prioritize that if indeed we even
keep it so that's just that's my
question well I don't know if anybody
here has an answer to it but I don't I'd
like to see a lot more information about
that Thanks I believe in advocating for
that regularly every chance I get I got
restaurants and lodging people that we
would increase the rooms and meals tax
twelve years ago whatever it was and but
we would give them the ability through
what is now the Business and Economic
Affairs Department to do advertising in
whatever markets would be most
reasonable to advertise in given the
economic situation so when we're in
recession and the rest of the world is
in recession they're going to go after
Massachusetts and Connecticut and etc
and maybe Quebec and when we're doing
for everybody's doing fairly well and
here traffic is cheap they go after
Europe and sometimes China maybe I'm not
sure go ahead
I would I sit on the New Hampshire
Travel Council and I believe this last
year they were funded at about eight
million dollars which there's a certain
percentage and I'm forgetting what that
percentage is of rooms and meals tax I
believe that they are allocated however
I think this is the first year they've
actually received the full allocation
and and typically their budget is raided
somewhat to fund other initial
in the state so I would urge you to
perhaps contact the New Hampshire Tribal
Council and and talk with them who can
speak much better at it I'm just a
member at large however I do think that
the state does an excellent job with the
resources that they have because New
Hampshire's budget for the advertising
and marketing tends to be much less than
other states and and yet we do receive
quite a bit of return on investment for
the dollars that are spent so certainly
someone from the council could speak
better to it but I think it's an
important part of the state and it
concerns chambers we have several member
executives who sit on the Travel Council
because we many of us do apply for the
jpp grants which come through the
Department of travel and tourism and we
use those funds to help with the
marketing of the state and in some cases
assisting our businesses and and those
funds go towards you know printing
guides or in some cases doing
advertising certainly you know the the
White Mountains receive its a lot of
benefit from that the Western White
Mountain Chamber the Mount Washington
Valley Chamber they use those funds very
effectively to help support that region
so I would definitely explore that
further I'd like to add that the money
is how much money is going to be
transferred over is in the budget each
time and I think it only went down
substantially when speaker O'Brien was
involved but they do they have had
studies showing that about $8 is created
for every $1 that's they're done by
Plymouth
University for every one dollar that we
spend which seems pretty good to me so
representative Romney had a question yes
this one's got to waiver I haven't
talked about that's entertainment
and we have theaters a lot of regional
theaters that are closed up right now is
the place or the venues that do being
Fisher Cats for instance have you heard
it from any of your members that our
members are that they want any of these
kind of businesses what are they
thinking about to me too many these are
going to be the businesses they're you
know the last because they're large
groups and small confined areas they
they are struggling significantly you
know here in Lebanon we have the Lebanon
Opera House we have a Opera Company
offer north
you know northern stage although that's
across the river and Vermont but but
still any empty venues like that
community theaters almost all of whom
are also nonprofit organizations so
there they're facing a double a double
whammy here if you will because not only
are they not allowed to open and have
their revenue in some cases some of the
shows that they've booked they have to
book sometimes almost a year in advance
and canceling an event like that they
still have expenses that are attributed
to that event even though it's been
canceled
there's contracts that have to be taken
care of and cancellation fees in some
case I I know our Lebanon Opera House
here in Lebanon
has let go all of their staff only their
executive director is left currently and
and it doesn't look like they will be
able to reopen and then on the other
side of that they also rely on donations
or contributions and those of course are
going to be down as well as as people
are hanging on to the money and their
wallet a little closer I think we will
see some of those clothes permanently as
well the ones that have the ability to
hold functions outdoors are doing a
little better I know the Tupelo Music
Hall recently built a stage outside and
did it like a drive-in theater you know
they had like a space in between it was
really kind of in junior that's the way
they did it not everybody's gonna be
able to do that not the Palace Theatre
not as I'm Tracey said the Opera House
many of the with someone in Portsmouth
I'm sorry I'm blanking out anyhow it's
yeah you know you know I'm talking about
movie theaters you know even if you did
other every other seat which is not six
feet I know they're trying to get
guidelines and they've been in front of
the reopening task force committee so
let's hope they come up with some
solutions movie theaters are actually
struggling a bit before coated our
nugget theater and Hanover has said that
they are struggling a bit because people
don't really go out to the movies as
much as they used to they wait for it to
come out on Netflix so they have seen a
downturn anyways and and now with this I
think I think it's going to be very
tough for them going forward and there
are also art galleries and music I don't
know what exactly we've got a music
program that's totally nonprofit in
Lebanon that that bought its own very
large house last year
all of those are having trouble figuring
out how they can provide services in
those cases because they were doing them
in smaller rooms with small groups I
think the other thing we have to look at
which kind of goes is kind of ecotourism
would be the big festivals in the state
of New Hampshire that draw tens of
thousands of people you know obviously
biker week up in the Lakes region all
the different pumpkin festivals we do
Tracy and I both ran the Milford Pumpkin
Festival at different times and we would
bring 45,000 people in over three days
and the economic impact for the area was
huge so just you know economic drivers
like that if we're restricted and can't
have big crowds which sounds to me like
we're not going to be able to until
there's a vaccine it's really going to
hurt the communities that rely on those
events hand up again these theaters are
closed these venues are closed
even if restaurants open these papers
are still closed we know that people who
are out and they don't go to restaurant
before or after the show that kind of
thing so that's why yes and there are a
lot of people who were getting income
from these these projects which are not
going to be spending income okay that's
a depressing way to end this anybody
bring music I I do want I can I can give
us a positive note we actually held a
ribbon-cutting last week for a new
business that just opened and happens to
be a restaurant in Enfield was obviously
was working on opening prior to the Copa
19 situation
but did open for takeout for about a
week and then the order came down that
they could do some outdoor seating and
there they're looking into that but they
have only been open about two weeks and
obviously they're having difficulties
for one they're having difficulties with
their supply chain
you know just obtaining you know the
sanitation mass and sanitizer and things
that are needed now and also meat has
been somewhat scarce to obtain in bulk
as well but still they're open and and
the community is supporting them so at
least you know there's a little bit of a
will hope that then it's only gonna take
a couple of years to get all of this
back that we've had before so Wendy and
and Tracy thank you very much for coming
thank you for having us talking - thank
you very much and we're going to have to
go talk with the insurance department
okay okay I can think of a lot more
but they we have in the audience
Christopher accomplice on the
commissioner and Kristy rice and Norma
Stallings who we know pretty well and I
think you want to present something to
us before we ask questions we got a
well I'm presuming that that's me this
is Norma talking okay thank you thank
you for having us sure okay well I
believe that you all did receive the
memo that I sent to Kris and it's
basically the same set up it I usually
have that page one we're talking about
the current fiscal year in what our
authorized budget was and what we are
where we're at now in what we think will
complete fiscal year 2020 and the chart
at the top of the page shows that we're
expecting approximately eight point
eight million dollars in excess of the
authorized budget and basically in the
next paragraph I break that down it
comprises of the premium tax being a
favorable variance of 5.8 million plus
the transfer to the granite Advantage
Health Trust was a million four point
five less than what was anticipated and
we have a million five in addition to
the P revenue that is generated by the
the various licenses and in departments
in the insurance department and then so
we can I forget down into each of the
components so that you can see what it
was that generated this additional eight
point eight million on page two that is
further detail of how the original
budget was calculated in
what we have for actual numbers and
again it there wasn't too much of a
difference in the tax base from what we
projected to what the actual laws the
line items that made up the biggest
difference is the retaliatory tax rate
which is the additional taxes that we
collect for those insurance companies
that are domiciled in other states other
than New Hampshire and I can tell you
that primarily the states that that
makes up or Delaware Massachusetts New
York Pennsylvania Rhode Island in
Vermont they are taxed at two percent so
even though their front they're writing
predominantly Property and Casualty
which new hampshire charges one and a
quarter we still collected at the two
percent so that's the we had an
additional half a million in the that
item the next one is the retaliatory
item tax base that's where if a again a
company who is domiciled in Delaware
they charge all their companies a fraud
fee of $900 so New Hampshire in turn any
of the Delaware companies that are
licensed in doing business in New
Hampshire will collect the $900 from
those Delaware companies and there are
several states that have these various
fees in predominantly
we collect from the Illinois companies
because they Illinois's well they have a
low premium tax rate they have an income
tax rate that they charge all insurance
companies and the other state that we
collect from is Massachusetts
Massachusetts has a number of assessment
in additional fees that are collected
from any of the companies doing business
in Massachusetts so that we ended up
with approximately million dollars more
than what was anticipated I mean when we
calculated the original budget excuse me
isn't this this is business people or
businesses that are getting insurance
hear from a Massachusetts or Delaware or
an Illinois company no these are all
insurance companies Oh insurance
companies are licensed in New Hampshire
mm-hmm there are they're domiciled in
state other states but they're licensed
in New Hampshire so any company that is
for instance licensed in Massachusetts
doing business in New Hampshire they
will pay to New Hampshire those fees in
tax rates that Massachusetts is charging
so it's simply the insurance companies
but the differences come from where the
company is domiciled but it is a New
Hampshire based company which is getting
insurance from an out-of-state place
that has higher rates for some reason
it's a New Hampshire resident that is
buying a policy from a company that is
domiciled in another state of New
Hampshire yes thank you okay and then
the rep some major has a question
relative to the corporate situation
have you made any changes to the
revenues especially yes yes we have that
is on page three that we have our
revised estimate for fiscal year twenty
twenty one twenty fiscal year twenty
twenty is not impacted by the pandemic
because that revenue is primarily
calculated on calendar year 2019 premium
written taxes are collected in March
2020 but the premiums were collected
back in 2019 okay so if we want to go on
to fiscal year 2021 we originally had an
estimate of 130 million 0.9 and we are
adjusting it downward to one hundred and
twenty eight point two million the areas
that we felt were going to show the
decrease is the property and casualty
line of business and also the
marketplace health premium we anticipate
that that because of the unemployment
and other factors of the health
insurance that that would go down as
well okay in on page three there's a
little narrative about some of the
factors that were considered in the
from our actuaries when they looked at
what the impact of the Cova nineteen
would have neighbor son I was on page
four by mistake okay page four is the
detail of and again that that shows the
individual line items that in more
detail of what we have but conversely
what we have here is that well we
decreased what I anticipated growth
rates were going to be we have had a
pretty consistent up turn to the
unlicensed companies those the surplus
lines or excess lines of business and
basically I increased what we
anticipated for that tax line based on
what the three-year average had been in
the same thing for license fees and
penalties the average for the last three
years has been closer to the eighteen
million so while we have a decrease in
what we anticipate for the license
companies premium taxes we have somewhat
of an offset of it of approximately two
million that are in the other two line
items so I don't see the reduction in
property and casualty in the detail okay
on page four the first line item is the
property and casualty the original
budget was two million five hundred and
forty three million and we've
crease that down to two billion 528
million yeah so that's where you're
going to get the definer adjustments
that were made in the calculations and
then a little bit further down you can
see the decrease in the medical
line-item net of the federal employee
program in Medicare Part D in Medicare
Advantage so that originally was
projected to have a premium growth of
2.5 million and we adjusted that
don't we also have the effect of the
tails that we would owe if we gave up
getting the tax instead of having the
entire year's tax paid up front and then
when we have a lower tax the next year
we have to we lose double and when we
have a higher text the next year we gain
double right you're talking about the
deferred revenue you know and if in the
past I believe that you all have used
the cash basis because that is what is
we have government operates is based on
a cash basis it's only at the end of the
fiscal year that there's an accounting
entry to account for that
prepayment that we collect in March that
actually applies for the time period of
July 1st to December 31st
adjust downward when we have less
premium what'll end up actually
happening is that there'll be an
adjustment to increase the premium take
taking out the amount of money out of
that deferred revenue account but I
don't think that my estimate would be
that that may be half a million dollars
there there would be an additional half
a million dollars from the deferred
revenue for fiscal year 2021 it's not
it's not huge I think one time we ended
the amount of the auto insurance
companies have been giving rebates is
that in consequential in terms of this
discussion some considerations about
consequential yes we did have the
property and casualty actuary look at
that and he did say that these paybacks
were going to have a small impact on
fiscal year 2020 it's a combination of
how they're paying it back whether they
treat it as a dividend and pay it back
this year or whether they're giving them
immediate credit for the next payment
that they did have do or they're
actually cutting them a checks is number
of variances I can tell you personally I
have three cars in I got twenty three
dollars back from the insurance company
so I'm not thinking it is it's going to
be a big amount of money that they are
going to be refunding and crediting and
just to follow up with what Norma said
there this is Krishna o'clock was the
Commissioner I think
worst-case scenario estimate was about
$380,000 so inconsequential if you
looked at what happened to these lines
during the Great Recession there does be
a history of a hardening of the market
but again the insurance industry in
itself it lags behind
traditionally all of the other
industries in the from what I've read it
would be first the commercial lines of
business the errors and omission
policies they would start getting more
expensive and the other part is that
when an insurance company they there are
reinsurance companies the reinsurance
companies are the traditional insurance
companies insurers so if they have a
block of business that they no longer
wish to retain the risk for they will
sign a reinsurance agreement with
another company and what I have read it
hasn't indicated that the reinsurance
companies they are going to also it's
going to become more expensive for the
insurance companies to acquire that
reinsurance so that but again that's not
in the near future in in New Hampshire
it has not had a enormous amount of
impact but again we're we're really
uncharted
territory right now so if in fact the
perception is that a industries
businesses feel the need to have more
coverage it will cost more money so what
you're saying is that that if we do get
an impact from this and the market gets
harder it's not really going to show up
for a few years correct because right
now fiscal year 2021 is based on what's
happening right now it's based on
calendar year 2020 mm-hmm
so it won't be until the policies that
are currently in place start to renew
and that I would expect would be in
calendar year 2021 so it definitely well
I shouldn't say anything nothing is
definite right now but I am confident
that it will take more than the near
future few months to have a significant
impact so it looks like if it happens it
would affect the next budget that
definitely by then your your national
level consultants that that work on
these things also have a better idea of
what's going on correct and we've the
actuaries they would see whatever the
rate requests are and they would have a
better idea of what is going to happen
as well thank you are there any further
and next we go to lottery is Charlie in
the audience or someone representing him
oh we're gonna min right now here he is
madam chair good afternoon
Charlie McIntyre for the lottery good
afternoon members of the committee good
afternoon this is the shortest document
you've ever given us I think the resume
yeah I mean certainly if I could I can
go through where our data suggests we
are it'll take about two minutes answer
questions I can only submit to you that
I worry about making estimates based on
never-before-seen data certainly my
experience in Lottery going back 17
years so I'll briefly go into it so draw
game sales are down tremendously that's
led by a Powerball Mega Millions which
are off collectively for the year forty
percent which is twenty-six million
dollars in sales that's a combination of
a lack of jackpots as well as a severe
drop in the bond factor which is what we
use to multiply the cash available to
advertise a jackpot
that being said both mega moons and
Powerball have rolling jackpots which if
they continue will increase revenues
keno year-over-year is up 12% meaning
the to this point this year versus to
the prior point last year but currently
when you compare the week's meaning
right now versus a year ago it's off 85
percent I'll say that's down because of
bars and taverns not being open and if
they are open they're open for take-out
only so folks are playing while they're
waiting for their food is that short
sports betting is off 70% this is
harder to quantify it we've uh little
bit up launched for five months but we
have seen a somewhat of a growth with
some sports coming back online we get a
tremendous amount of business in the
golf match between Tiger Woods and Phil
Mickelson on Saturday with Tom Brady and
Peyton Manning we also with the launch
of the Bundesliga which is the European
soccer league has seen the launch a
growth as well so would have been off
about 85% is off 70% charitable gambling
is off 100% that yields a loss of about
a million dollars a month for charities
as well as a quarter million dollars for
the state monthly internet lottery is up
significantly as you can imagine folks
now can play from their homes so they
will and what is the most puzzling to us
is scratch ticket sales which had been
off 15% during the trough of the kovin
are now running at a rate consistent
with Christmas we have done two weeks
back-to-back of six million dollars in
sales which is more than we did the
Christmas season so in the past week our
sales are up 23% which is tremendously
from adjectives on this tremendously
anomalous and that doesn't compare with
our neighbors Massachusetts of the same
period is down 2% Maine is up 7 and
Vermont is up 11 so we're up double
versus what would be a nearest
comparator and nor is it statewide in
some regions were off significantly and
some regions were up significantly and
so I hate to sort of call it a trend
it's only two weeks and it's not
statewide and so if that trend were to
continue certainly we that coupled with
new sports coming online we would run
raise estimates currently I believe we
provided guidance of 95 million for this
year and a hundred million for next year
it is likely in the next week and a half
two weeks we would
this year's fiscal estimate
significantly and certainly with my very
brief notes to you madam chair
those are our the variables we have in
play right now in terms of the revenues
for this fiscal year next to school year
and happy to answer any questions you
may have
about anything thank you I was trying to
find your actual estimates which are in
the sheet that that cuz she gave us that
I hadn't been looking at so far would
you mind repeating what you thought you
might you currently have 95 million for
this year yes yes
so that's supported by 5 million from
last year that was transferred into this
year for a couple of reasons one is and
as you know we trained through at the
end of June for June sales before they
happened so easily are conservative with
that transfer and then also there was an
adjustment by the LBA auditors for a
retirement which yielded a positive 3
million dollar amount so of the 95 5
million of that is from last year to
believe our estimate for the year for
the budget was a hundred million hundred
million point four I believe yes so I
would I'm sorry but I'm just next so
it's like the next ten days if the
trends continue because I do hate
calling a trend after just a couple of
weeks I would anticipate us raising
guidance in the next week or two weeks
and you could raise it how much do you
think you might regice it if they
continue symmetry 3.5 million so we
between 1798 one hundred million dollars
if the trends continue and Mega Millions
rolls again which it has been for now 18
weeks okay so then all of next year's
you think will be be it a hundred
million which is what we were expecting
for this year before all this happened
so you think it's still gonna take a
while to get back what you were looking
at before yes I mean certainly I was
somewhere like I said we made the
estimates and did the work before we saw
what was a significant growth in scratch
ticket sales and like no time and our my
history certainly with the lottery and
the folks that work with is it harder to
estimate retail behavior but by players
of a discretionary product only because
the we saw the bottom and the top
happened within a month of each other in
my history of lottery sales which is not
common and so it's hard to sort of plan
out for the next year when it's been
inconsistent with the last six weeks but
hopefully by next year they'll have
figured out sports betting again I hope
I hope honestly a large portion of our
sports betting estimates for a full year
relate to a physical location being open
and smoothly distancing within a
physical location will be obviously
tricky but in a weird sense they're
actually benefits by having real sports
or major sports up and running with no
fans because folks want to have the fan
like environment and they can't do it at
the facility as in the stadium they
would they will do it at a physical
sports book location if that makes sense
I'll be opening the physical sparse
locations not yet no they're not open
but they're slated to open as soon as
they can
one in Seabrook was ready to open five
days before we in March before we closed
everything now we're close to the bars
and taverns down and they closed down in
in lockstep with those how much of this
of these scratch tickets comes from from
convenience stores first as far as in
taverns crash ticket sales
oh it's 98 percent 97 percent the
greatest loss in scratch ticket sales
has been the stores that no longer carry
temporarily some closed permanently the
Market Basket chain has stopped selling
lottery tickets during this period so
we've seen a loss in sales in their.what
bars and taverns is is negligible in
terms of what they sell for Sky's
tickets the scratch tickets to that
point madam chair scratch ticket is our
number-one revenue source for the state
it's represents more than half of our
Yeah right so some of the stores have
closed completely and the numbers of
just discontinued it for now
correct correct they don't like the
transfer the clothes transfer of the
transaction and happening review and
some like a Hannaford's only sell
through the machine the terminal that
says you want and they don't sell the
customer service anymore now right and
Market Basket it's just not not selling
at all
they're not sewing at all correct as you
can imagine Market Basket is one of our
larger chains
yes stores okay we've got three
questions now well I was waiting but
I've said a major thank you I was
looking the official plan for 2020 it
was a hundred point floor so whoever's
estimate of 95 will be down five point
four for 2020 and the official plan for
2021 is a hundred and ten point four and
some Charley's estimate weed out 10
million dogs that's correct
represent a major and those are what I
would characterize is conservative
estimates okay okay mm-hmm yeah there's
the scratch ticket issue and there's
sports betting opening up further yes
the ten million dollar increase for 2021
is actually basically scratched sports
betting launching as a as a product line
and making ten million dollars profit
okay so the next question is represent
over bra me
yeah I'm just curious Charlie how about
Tara or gaming I know it's a small
there's no extensive while revenue but
my understanding is that they are
conversations going on about opening
them what are you hearing certainly I
know that members of the charitable
gaming operators and charities appeared
before the reopening Commission and made
their case about how they can do it as a
as a prot as a center for profit for the
state it's not really a profitable
enterprise we make about two and a half
three million dollars it covers
essentially the cost of regulating them
but I do know the charitable community
has been very vocal about how much money
they're losing because they all all
these dates were scheduled as you can
imagine all these March states April
dates and made dates and now the
charities that have had dates are gone
and so they're losing I said a little
over a million dollars a month in just
direct revenue to charities so I know
they're clamoring to reopen again since
both places see but a big an example you
used is it would it be true that the it
would all happen all at once
if they know if their channel gaming is
not open in sports because an open
always separate issues I mean there's
separate facilities there actually in
case of Seabrook they're in different
sections of Seabrook and mousey I know
you know that facility pretty well yeah
and it hasn't been determined certainly
it's in pencil not panas to when they
open they were ready to go
in March like they the equipment's in
place the wirings in place the
televisions had been mounted the trading
platform was built already so it's quite
little your switch for us
some of the other locations also
terrible gaming locations yes the second
location is going to be the Manchester
and they all saw our charitable gambling
hall one of the benefits to charitable
gambling facilities doing this is that
they have most of the operations in
place most of eternal controls in place
they have surveillance in place and they
have what we found out to be through our
research very much more likely folks
interested in sports betting because if
you like to play you know cards you like
to bet on sports to a much much higher
degree so the Manchester facility I
say because a lot of elbow room be tied
to chair or gaming opening at the same
time I would think so I mean I thought
they would think so yes okay that's one
thank you yeah and also the partners
that are chosen are chosen by draftkings
based on a number of factors that we
then approved it's not our choice it's
draftkings this looks for maximum
utilization of what would be a player
base as well as the courts with their
brand standards as it were so how many
more places get to get chosen
they'll be recurring one at a time
obviously that process was slowed
dramatically by this whole affair and
obviously it has to be in a town or city
that approved so numbers three and four
are very much in pencil one out see we'd
like to put up with north country and
then one a second or a fourth one on the
border as well it was our hope that we
would have a fourth location identified
but we don't yet our third fourth but
we're gonna be building them one at a
time
where this for the long haul as you can
imagine so we don't want to make a
mistake on a bill said is next I just
going back to the scratch ticket Shelley
I'm wondering how big of a component of
the revenue is component you know not
the physical ticket question if I can
answer it yes yes I believe what
percentage of the scratch tickets is the
physical ones versus what percentage are
the virtual ones through the internet
yeah so our profitability this year is
about
well estimated about 55 million on
scratch tickets 54 56 depending on what
happens in the next five six weeks and
our scratch ticket profitability on the
internet will be around six so it's a
factor of one to ten
okay and the next question is analyzed
and your need to be there I a little bit
more about charitable gaming I'm on a
board that has missed its date this year
and we had a considerable conversation
about that yesterday in a board meeting
and a development committee meeting and
that grew I think from just listening in
on that conversation it was the
organization itself like in our case is
very confusing about how to move forward
with this on the charitable gaming front
[Music]
its III didn't I couldn't offer any real
advice on how to proceed I think that
revenue for us is gone
for the year I don't know how to get
back in that list and I am so I have a
question about the future of charitable
gaming and how effective it's going to
be if it's gonna if we can't get things
up and running and and to my group just
say forget about it that's that's an
observation
question or a comment or I mean it's
just it's been it's been frustrating
that's all I guess that was a comment
thank you represent Burstein is last I
think and he needs to be opened up to
thank you uh hi Charlie thanks for
coming today
course I like your first bullet point
regarding the variables it says that no
more than 2% of the businesses that
carry our products fail and you say
businesses is that a synonym for outlets
you account Hannaford's as one or as
however many establishments they have
and why'd you focus on 2% when we read
about the I'm reading 20 30 40 % of
restaurants are not gonna reopen now I
know that that's not a hunt that's a
subset of the universe that you're
citing but 2% I just want you to double
click on that number for of course yeah
as you can imagine we anticipate across
the spectrum
assemblé will fail at a higher rate
obviously when you look at the number of
bars and taverns we have now it's only
about 190 so while a larger portion of
bars may fail because of the lack of
business the vast majority of our
current businesses we do business with
are considered essential and still up
and running so community stores
supermarkets - stations like we do 51
percent of our sales of traditional
lottery through C stores with gas so
they're still up and running and still
in business
and so while they've been affected it
hasn't been the same level so that's why
I don't anticipate a much higher failure
rate and I knock on wood heartily with
that statement amongst our retail
network see your question representative
then you would like restaurants we don't
count on free for the majority of our
revenues we only kind of known for keno
which this year was going to net us
around six or six to eight million
dollars which will be less than that
will be probably five to six so we the
failure rate amongst them at a higher
rate while tragic is not as impactful in
so keenum is still going on yes it's so
we're doing about 150 thousand dollars a
week in keno and before the crisis
started we had had a few best weeks ever
when we're doing about eight hundred
thousand eight hundred forty thousand a
week so it's quite literally folks going
to a place that serves food ordering
they're allowed to congregate to play
but not to eat it sounds like I was
wondering about then yeah I guess I I
think they're socially distancing within
a closed restaurant for six feet apart
buying tickets in you can play a bunch
of numbers at once you don't have to buy
them one at a time you could play ten
and months and wait for ten draws if you
were so wish and they think it's a good
four years so you could play ten tickets
leave immediately and they're good for a
year okay any further questions
looks like we've we've done that thank
you very much charlie
thanks a lot bud you know somebody thank
[Music]
we have coming in the Commissioner
Malika and Tina in tumors the chief
financial officer good afternoon madam
chair members of the committee Jo Malta
and Enid Amir's from the Liquor
Commission and Tina will run you through
the numbers and let you know where we're
at
good afternoon the document that you
have in front of you shows our original
plan for liquor of 130 2.8 million we're
projecting a revised plan of 130 point 1
million which is a 2.7 million off that
plan that is primarily mainly due to the
Hampton properties and not selling the
property to be able to pay off our debt
so as far as our revenue from liquor
sales we're on target for making those
projections and looking at the 2021 the
plan is 130 3.8 million we're revising
that to 131 point 1 which could go up if
we sell the Hampton properties within
next fiscal year so some of those
revenues were put in because of the
change of selling those properties and
paying off those bonds and those
properties have not been sold yet the
RFP for the realtor's has gone out and
we should be making a selection for a
realtor soon to have that sale go
through but it would go through after
Jim that's correct madam chair yes I was
just gonna go through the beer tax so
the beer tax plan is 13 point 1 million
we're revising our estimate to about
twelve point eight million which
is about $300,000 off the plan and for
fiscal year 2021 the plan was 13 point 1
million we've revised the estimate to 12
point 9 which is about 200,000 off the
plan what I wanted to ask about was
there's been a 2.7 million change in
both each in each year amounting to 5.2
total for the biennium and they're both
related to the same property or correct
correct because what was put in there
was selling off the properties at the
beginning of this fiscal year and being
able to pay down our debt which would
have decreased our bond payments by that
2.7 million in each of the fiscal years
[Music]
makes a lot more sense thank you you're
welcome
so other than that our plan remains
unchanged as to what you see in front of
you we hear that liquor is being deluged
with customers now well our sales at our
at our outlets are up 5.2 percent or
nearly 34 million dollars
obviously our partners in the restaurant
world have been distressed greatly by
the covin pandemic and we're not seeing
or recognizing any sales from them that
are significant at this point as they
begin to reopen we are seeing some sales
come back it's it's not a large amount
of money but we're wishing them the best
of course they're our partners and
they're devastated by this yes what
not they not the whole sales know what
what you're looking at is are yes our
total revenue he was just saving where
we're at currently and up until right
all the growth all the growth has been
in retail madam chair right okay we've
got two questions
representative Rami yes thank you
um last time we can it was a couple
months ago I guess because you couldn't
couldn't find step pretty much been
resolved yes you were doing some kind of
a bonus or something upon payment sure
the governor in an executive order
allowed the Liquor Commission to offer a
10% increase hourly increase for our
employees in the outlets our sales
employees that is still going on to this
point at one point we had as many as
five hundred and sixty-eight employees
out of the workplace out of about 1200
we had 15 outlets close at this point we
still have 14 outlets closed we're
reopening three outlets prior to the
seventh of June and we have we still
have about a hundred and eighty six
people out of the workplace both full
and part-time and we just did a
consolidation of our Franklin and
Belmont stores into the new Tilton
I was along the same line I was just
wondering now what the net impact was of
having the approximately 15 stores that
were closed and
and you know what your your thoughts
were you know short of any new new
pandemic got burst here when you would
plan to be be back and fully operational
so retail close it Thank You
representative closing the outlets and
decreasing the hours all the outlets are
now open from 11:00 to 6:00 the the
impact on sales has not been negative to
the contrary the impact on sales has
been positive as I've said we're up
5.20% or nearly 33.86 million dollars so
having those stores closed and reducing
the hours in the stores that have had a
net positive effect being that the
restaurants are closed a lot of the
restaurants are still closed so our goal
in the future is to look for the
efficiencies in the reduced hours and in
the reduced stores and those are some
studies that we're doing now as I've
said we've reopened as of as of
yesterday we had one store in Milford
that was reopened about a week ago we
plan on reopening the stores around the
lake prior to the seventh and then we'll
take the rest of the stores in priority
of revenue revenue production as we
reopen them there's a string of you had
a follow up to the fault based on what
I'm hearing you saying part of your
long-term plan may be to close five or
ten of these stores permanently no no
that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that with this stores
being closed and our business partners
in there on the restaurant side what we
call our on-premise partners and reduced
hours the revenue still rose by nearly
thirty four million dollars so what
we're looking to do is
make sure that when we reopen these
stores and when we look at expanding the
hours we continue to do it as
effectively and efficiently as possible
so you may see some of these stores in
the future not open as early or stay
open as late we're doing a heat graph on
where our business is and the hours that
were seeing and obviously we're seeing
some cross-border traffic back into the
state are our stores on the highways the
tolls were down by as much as 50 percent
at some point and our stores on the
highway which are obviously our top two
in our top ten stores we're seeing
revenue loss of as much as 50 percent
and the in town stores and some of the
smaller locations are the stores that
are actually doing the increased
business so we're looking at all the
trends that are taking place during the
pandemic and transferring that
information across as we reopen these
stores so we can do it as effectively
and efficiently as possible so we do not
have I do not have a number of stores
that are going to close but I do have is
some consolidations in some opening of
new stores and what I what I do perceive
to happen in the future is some reduced
hours in some of the outlets but
obviously the governor is tasked us with
efficiencies and we're looking to any
efficiencies that we can possibly make
to keep our revenues where they need to
be and at this point other than that
change for the the property that has not
been sold in Hampton yet we are on
target to make our revenue plan right we
appreciate it
represented major you had a question yes
the sale the property you feel pretty
confident and FY 21 of you sold
we do we fat we've we had a number of
Realtors come to look at the property
and we had some very some very positive
feedback from a lot of the people that
are out there obviously we've had a lot
of interest over the years since there's
been a plan to sell this property and I
feel that we will have a sale in 2021
and for the amount of money you had
anticipated I I feel that that's still a
veins yeah thank you thank you
so actually two questions the first one
is the I don't know what it was called
the essential workers payment extra
money or um for your bonus for your
workers and I believe that comes to an
end at some point
and what's your plan beyond yes I think
I remember that's out of federal money
or not out of our state budget directly
so this one has one question maybe I
should start there well that was a 10%
raise representative that was put in
place by the governor across the board
for any of the frontline workers in our
stores you know that has an end date
along with with the proclamation put
forth but there's not an end date in
place at this point and that is money
that is state funded that is not
federally funded money it's in our
revenue estimate I thought that Biser
increase in sales it's a small dollar
amount that's helpful I didn't know that
yes the entire expenses from from the
Liquor Commission are taken out now
okay and then the other question is
quite different it last time you were
before us a year ago or so you were
telling us about the competition from a
very big store or maybe there were a
couple of them one of them positioned
well positioned in Northeast
Massachusetts and I'm wondering what the
story is today on all of that that's
total wine and spirits which are they
are as as I reported before they are the
largest brick-and-mortar beverage
alcohol retailer in the United States
about a hundred and forty stores in 23
states six stores in Massachusetts all
east of Northborough so they're all on
the inside of the 495 belt they've
positioned them obviously in areas that
could have presumably affected our
business in New Hampshire they have been
impacted significantly by this as well
and not only not only in Massachusetts
you know they remain a constant factor
against our marketing and our and our
management of what we do you know
they're they're a constant competitor
they've been affected as everyone has so
you know I I think that I would say that
nothing has changed from from the
standpoint of who they are or how they
run their business we have effectively
managed and market marketed against any
type of you know downward trend that the
Liquor Commission might take given the
size of the retailer they've begun in
the last six months they typically come
in they build a number of stores they
undercut everybody in the market by 10
20 30 %
they gain they gain some business mainly
private label retailer and they gain
some business and then they start to
raise their prices and they've they've
done that in Massachusetts they follow
trend so to this point their prices are
in a lot of cases actually higher than
what we charge and in some cases equal
to what we charge so there their
effectiveness in marketing against the
Liquor Commission has you know been
nullified at this point they're a
good thank you welcome thank you for the
question it's gone again yes it's gone
again okay now is the curiosity big
picture question terms of the people who
produce all your product if you will is
there any supply chain issues
no we know at this point we haven't seen
any supply chain issues either from the
distillery standpoint or the winery
standpoint in fact there's been a glut
of red wine especially out of California
and France so I think we'll be enjoying
some great buys over the next few months
and obviously next month is our American
wine sale so I would I would ask
everybody to take a look at the stores
if you're an American wine enthusiast
and and buy-in thank you okay anybody
else looks like we've got it thank you
very much thank you manicure question
shei which is as i recall on you take a
percentage of the overhead to from the
revenues each month to put into to what
we get in the monthly revenue focus and
did you add in the 10% extra staffing
cost so so in the revenue in the revenue
focus that's done by administrative
services right so all the information
comes directly from the liquor
administrator the Liquor Commission
actually estimates each month way what
it is and sends it over correct
great thank you I thought we trued up at
the end of the year thank you very much
you kids well thank you safety good
afternoon madam chair good afternoon
members of the committee
Steve Lavoie director of administration
for the Department of Safety so you have
our our revenue projections what I
thought I'd do is just kind of give an
overview of some of the assumptions that
we've made in arriving at these figures
you see the big caveat with all of these
amounts is that we've done our best to
consider all the available data when
developing these projections but
everything is is subject to change and
we've never experienced this condition
before so everybody who's trying to find
the right pieces of paper we have a FY
22 21 plan versus projected
the Department of Safety and that one on
I guess we don't have to to compare it
with the one that's in the worksheet
that was given to us I apologize
at first I couldn't figure it out so go
ahead okay thank you
so we when we established our
projections we made some high-level
assumptions we started with looking at
the impact on our April revenue
collections and and carry that forward
the FY 20 and then into FY 21 and we
assumed that there'd be a slow and
steady recovery throughout the end of
calendar year 20 into December but that
we would still have an overall decline
moving forward into January from January
into July for the end of FY 21 so high
level that's the approach that we took
for all of our revenue sources and what
I'll do is I'll go through each one
individually and provide you with a
little bit more detail on on those those
specific assumptions so road toll
typically with road toll I talked to you
about three different factors that
impact it the impact fuel consumption
and that's price weather and the economy
and oftentimes we're really worried
about weather and we're really worried
about price right now the economic
conditions are really putting though
that's where the big focus is price is
it is it positive right now it's it's
extremely low a dollar 96 for a gallon
of gasoline it's expected to stay low
based on US Energy Information
Administration estimates only seek only
reaching two dollars by the end of FY
2008 Allender year twenty and then two
dollars seventeen cents by calendar year
21 but even though it's low and even
though the weather's good especially
good right now the economic impact that
COBIT has had is is keeping people off
of the roads and so that's really having
that the heaviest weight and downward
pressure on our Road toll collections so
what that's leading us to when we're
looking at track
the crates we reach out with do T&C what
they're seeing on the roads
they started off at the beginning of the
Cova Deven over 50% decline in traffic
as we're moving through this month it's
starting to recover somewhat we're in
the 40s range now according to do T and
that's really aligning with what we're
seeing in road toll collections also so
for road toll projections for the rest
of FY 21 FY 20 we're projecting to
collect one hundred and fourteen point
seven million that's an eleven point
nine percent decrease from plan this
assumption where we're making is that
we'll have a fifty percent
year-over-year decrease in collections
in both May and June this is based off
of our April collections which were down
25% with Road told we're collecting in
arrears so our on April collections on
April 20th actually represents March
usage then we looked at that 25% number
we realized that's half of a month of
kovat impact so it made sense to
increase that to a 50% impact for May
and June the good news is is our
preliminary May amounts are coming in
closer to 40% so it looks like we were
overly conservative there the difference
there could is about a million dollars
in revenue so that is positive but we're
going to keep an eye on that especially
as we're seeing more traffic out there
on the roads carrying that forward into
FY 21 we're projecting to collect one
hundred and fifteen point six million in
road toll which is twelve point six
percent lesson plan and we assumed a 40%
decrease year-over-year in July
collections and that's slowly increasing
to a five percent decrease in December
and then we have you either a three or a
two percent decrease for the remainder
of January through June so again trying
to capture the impact of a recovery over
the next six months but realizing that
there will be a longer-term impact on on
revenue collections for Road toll could
you send those monthly charts to us the
MA
a monthly estimate you're reading from
yeah these are these are a summary of
those sheets I can absolutely send you
the details great thank you the next
major source of revenue has to do with
DMV so one of the good news a little bit
of good news is that many of the DMV
sources the revenue is not going to
necessarily disappear or be lost like
like Road toll that will be shifted DMV
has worked hard to stay open as best as
they can and they're offering services
online by appointment by phone there's
Dropbox's at eight locations and so
that's really helped to minimize the
impact on our DMV generated revenue
registrations is the first area we're
projecting to collect eighty four point
two million in twenty which is about one
percent less than plan April was down
twelve percent and we assumed a fifteen
percent decrease in May and a ten
percent decrease in June and then
carrying that forward into twenty one
we're projecting to collect eighty two
point six million which is three percent
less than plan and that assumed is a ten
percent decrease in July improving to a
five percent decrease through December
and then that's three to two percent
decrease for January through June motor
vehicle operators this is your license
revenue so again customers here can
renew online once every ten years and
we've also DMV also is allowing through
through executive order has been allowed
to expired licenses or those who will
expire by June 30 could apply for a six
month extension and so what that did was
allowed us to collect that revenue now
instead of having it shift into future
periods and also Real ID compliance that
deadline has been extended to October
and so that's that was an important
piece that that the customers were
concerned about rejecting out our
revenues for FY 24 expecting to collect
eleven point eight million in an
operator's revenue which is eleven
percent less than plan
Apryl revenue collections were down 43%
and our fy2010 assumes a 45 percent
decrease in May and a 50% decrease in
June and then projecting to collect in
FY 21 7.3 million which is a thirteen
point eight percent decrease from plan
it's significantly lower than FY 20 but
that was a planned dip because of the
the dip here when we moved from a four
year to a five year license renewal and
so that's already been accounted for in
our plan numbers which is why the
percentage is relatively consistent with
the prior year projection moving on to
inspection station fees we're projecting
to collect 3.9 million which is a 7%
over plan we had collected additional
revenues throughout the year which is
why there's an increase here
however April was still down thirteen
point eight percent and we carried that
forward into a 15 percent decrease in
May and a 10 percent decrease in June to
arrive at the three point nine and then
we're also projecting to collect three
point nine and FY twenty one that starts
with an assumption of fifteen percent
decrease in July through the five
percent increase in December and then
the overall three to two percent
decrease for the second half of the year
motor vehicle title the automobile
dealers are still open and DMV still
providing title services they they there
has been a drop that we've seen based on
that we're projecting to collect eight
point six million in revenues in FY 2011
point six percent decline from plan
April was down fifty three percent and
we assumed a fifty three percent
decrease in May and a fifty percent
decrease in June then we're projecting
nine point four percent in collections
in FY 21 which is four point three
percent less than planned
and this assumes a decrease of twenty
five percent in July improving to a five
percent decrease through December and
then the overall three to two percent
decrease for the rest of the year and
then finally miscellaneous fees
these this is the area that includes
plea by male court fines licensed
restorations and some other
miscellaneous fees here we're projecting
to collect 16 million in FY 25.2%
decline from plan April we're down 54%
and we're assuming a 50% decrease in May
and a 61 percent decrease in June and
then we're projecting to collect sixteen
point six million in FY 21 which is a
four point one percent four point one
percent under plan and as these
assumptions are an average decrease of
fifty percent in July improving to five
percent through December and a three to
two percent decline for the rest of the
fiscal year so again our total highway
fund revenues for FY 2002 two hundred
and thirty nine point four million which
is just under twenty million short of
plan and then we're projecting for FY 21
to be two hundred and thirty-four point
nine million which is again just over
two twenty one just 21 million short
plan or eight point two percent and I'm
happy to take any questions that you
have related to those to those estimates
I would really like to get the month by
month you've been talking for us it's
difficult to follow without them your
yeah I'm happy to provide that I'll
provide that to come here to the
committee mm-hmm to the committee why
can you do it tomorrow your then or
today jammer thank you you can go ahead
and send it through me okay then I'll
make sure that committee gets it me has
a question yeah we we talk about another
conversations with others that auto
sales were down I just unpacked you
folks because people just hang on to
their cars I'm registered
cars versus registering a new car but I
just had a random thought for everybody
that I think this is gonna impact our
towns because theirs is the revenue
talents get from registrations a lot
more than the state in terms of based on
the value of the car so that's something
that we should all keep in mind with our
towns yeah just using my party yeah
absolutely right because we are at the
state level it's the the fee is based on
weight so that's not going to change if
you hold your vehicle longer we won't be
impacted but the town's absolutely will
be because the value is going to
continue to decrease if spent that and a
lot of property tax uncollectible so any
further questions about this one then
thank you Oh how do you how do you have
the state troopers just estimating how
much traffic they're seeing on the roads
is that how you've been doing that as
far as the plea by mail amounts and
those those figures know you were
talking about the traffic oh yes I'm
sorry
so do t has traffic counters on the
turnpike system and then they some some
equipment and other areas across the
state and we we typically reach out the
d-o-t and ask them what they're seeing
from their traffic counting is they're
very concerned about that for turnpike
system purposes and we incorporate that
data into our analysis thank you so this
is biased towards the big birds yes
though I must say I've been seeing a
whole lot of traffic until recently on
the other roads
but recently things have been getting a
lot they may be half normal at this
point and they keep going Aryan
I'm certainly seeing more traffic over
the last two weeks on the way in driving
it I've been seeing more traffic heading
into Concord that I have a month ago so
I'm noticing it anecdotally as well and
there's an awful lot of construction
being done hmm there's always
construction being done good yeah a lot
more smaller projects so you think
you're finished with one and you go
has a question yes um on the traffic
looking at the post from the State
Police it should also be a rather large
increase in plea by mail although most
of the ones that they're publishing on
their website they're going to have to
appear in person because they're gonna
go to jail for doing 134 through a
construction zone but speeding is up
stops by speeding up and as a result
that will generate unfortunately I hate
to say it but it will generate more
revenues as opposed to 50 $10 fines
there's going to be five five hundred
dollar fines just numbers not facts just
just as a point of consideration on that
done that would be interesting we
usually see fines going down during
during recessions driving faster much
faster
I mean um up your area they just had a
guy coming down the hill he was doing a
hundred miles an hour going down the
hill heading into Lebanon
I mean yeah it's easy to feed there but
I'm miles an hour that one didn't even
get into her our city's police bulletin
Wow
don't buy the State Police thing okay we
only look at this at the city one thank
you so any further questions and thank
you very much Steve thank you thank you
everyone and now we get to doing this
have people been looking presentations
because the idea was that we would ask
questions if we had anyone and we'd
bring someone up from the audience to
discuss them but in order to ask
questions we have to evolve look we have
to have looked at this but I'd say we've
got four we've got a number of things in
the judicial system which which does not
provide a huge amount of money to us but
which seemed a little noteworthy that
the fees from background checks that
made sense that to me that the fee is
from background checks have gone down
considerably because employers are not
employing no people and because
landlords are not going to be able to
find very many tenants to replace the
people is they're going to evict and
they can't evict anybody at the moment
and there is a question entry fees which
is also landlord-tenant issue that those
are expected to go go down quite a lot
because of the governor's mandate but in
considerably the next year which makes
now the only restaurant of Romney's got
his hand raised
Oh representative Romney
oh yes on the summer heat you want court
fines and fees yes court fines and fees
okay before I make sure if there's
somebody from street they drop in from
this year if that's what you're trying
to get out there but yes we have Donna
Raymond from the courts and Chris
Keating from the courts that can respond
to any questions you might have is the
entire amount you mean yes Joe is that
better yes okay sorry
so actually I I let the actual data sort
of inform my projection and attached to
the spreadsheet that was sent it's
actually an Excel back in that there are
hidden have them there one of them is
the day-by-day revenues that we
collected in each one of these revenue
accounts but we have sort of the
pre-pandemic through March 13 revenues
and then we have a post March 16 and on
and I looked at what was happening we
had it was interesting you sort of saw
the week of March 16 through March 20
was sort of a transition week where
that's when you really saw things slide
and then things sort of leveled off week
after the governor stay-at-home order
was issued Oh then so obviously great
but I tried to let those several weeks
after in an for
what was going to happen in terms of
fiscal year 21 sort of a low-end and a
high-end not really knowing how all of
these factors were going to influence
the numbers I think you know there are a
couple of things at play obviously stay
at home is going to have somewhat of an
immediate impact but as the state opens
up we've already seen in the last month
anecdotally we've seen more cars on the
road so that's a good time do you
believe though that the unemployment
issue is going to inflict a deeper wound
that's going to take longer to heal
that's also going to and some of the
revenues that we take in penalty
assessments for admin fees from Safety
and Motor Vehicles is they're all motor
vehicle related in some way so I try
each each of the four quarters in fiscal
year 21 estimate what I thought was
gonna happen percentage-wise of an
improvement in fact that into the
overall figures that you see there so in
short I tried to look at different
factors at play what I thought was going
to be happening on a quarterly basis
having it informed by what we saw things
more quickly where court appearances
what's going on is there pent up bunch
of cases out there so Donna I'll try to
answer that Chris Keating Donna do you
want to give it a try
you mean Chris is your phone muted yeah
nope here we go
can you hear me now yes there you go so
the courts have been trying to limit the
number of people who come into the
courthouses since this started to just
emergency hearings people seeking
protections from abuse guardianship so
ver incapacitated people and the like
but we've been open for business and
every single courthouse has been open
all day long every working day and what
we're trying to do is get the word out
to lawyers that we are wide open to take
anything that they can accomplish over a
WebEx session over a teleconference or
by paper and so it's been a struggle to
get the word out to lawyers because the
lawyers have been so accustomed to
showing up in court with a client but
the the administrative judges have been
trying to get the word out to to lawyers
and anybody who'll listen that we are we
are willing to to entertain any creative
method to resolve cases so if people
want to submit a plea to a DWI we'll do
it by paper we're even doing pleas in
felony cases by paper and and these are
self-report people to stand committed
sentences at the jails on paper we're
doing just an astounding amount of work
now we've got all of the courts set up
on WebEx to do hearings by WebEx and
evidentiary hearings where people are
submitting documents electronically so
we're just we not until June 15th are we
letting more people into courthouses to
conduct to conduct here things and
they're sort of regular business but
even so we probably won't go back to
as many in-person hearings as we used to
and we really do we really plan to do a
lot of stuff by this method ideally
without the crazy echoing but in the
future or just try to try to resolve
cases as efficiently as possible and so
you know the message that I would say is
have have you have your constituents or
friends lawyers just get in touch with
the clerk and make arrangements to get
absolutely sir there is kind of
situations yes sir we've we've cancelled
in the circuit court 30,000 hearings
that that need to be not all of them
will be put back on the docket but at
least 30% of them will need to be put
back on the docket you know because some
work you know anticipatory dispositional
type hearings that you know are just
never gonna happen again but but
resolving the case will happen which
will result in in in fees and fines
getting ordered by the court and
collected by the court and delivered to
Treasury I might also add to the Senate
maybe helpful we are continuing to make
inroads in sort of transforming the
courts we are in the process now of
deploying some of our staff as well as
Bureau of court facility staff to visit
a small medium and large court across
the state we're gonna be figuring out
what we need to do to get the social
distancing in place the signage the
stanchions the tape on the floors and
then your court facilities is going to
go out to all of our force and get that
set up and the goal is to have all of
that marked off by June 15 so that will
allow us to control a little bit more
what's going on inside the courtrooms in
terms of equipment I think we're we're
pretty well stocked in terms of masks
I mean sanitary sanitization supplies
that we need kind of taking things in
steps and then see are we on solid
footing with what we're doing before we
arrest two other things we've also
requested nearly a hundred laptops that
we hopefully funded through the cares
Act funding to see if we can again
transition some of what we do more
remotely issues to we want to consider
are there ways that people can handle
hearings by phone if we have individual
has a phone and a smartphone and the
court has a smartphone and we do
something with that but again get
complicated but I think we're trying to
do things you know step by step and see
how we go but we're continuing to make
inroads with this thank you could I ask
a question about that
I think I'm reading this chart correctly
the plan for this year was almost twenty
million including the highway money and
I'll just include for the moment and
you're projecting almost eighteen
million
but next year with all these changes
you're planning on ten and a half
million to twelve point eight million
prepped which is a lot less than what
you think we're getting out of this year
so after you've made all those changes
and you're starting to catch up you see
you still think sorry we're going to end
up with a lot less revenue I think what
I'm concerned about is the deep impact
this is having on the economy overall I
was not with the judicial branch in 2008
I'm fortunate I joined in June of 2012
but it would be interesting to compare
what the impact to revenues was in that
scenario because the only difference
there well a primary difference is to
say at home order that's in place now
but economy being hard-hit this
as well as last time but I suspect even
as you had mentioned when we have a bad
economic downturn you see motor vehicle
fines and things they tend to drop off
yeah I'm anticipating some of that but
again it's just it's more you know the
stay-at-home orders are gonna lift they
don't open up more so that will help
things but I just think it's going to
take a long time for the economy overall
to recover people still get me out of
work I'm hoping I'm wrong I serve it up
in my estimates and I'd be pleasantly
ourselves I don't remember anything like
this steep ever and I was you're screwed
it's a Great Recession I was here for
ten years before that
yeah again I'll be looking at a month by
month and well obviously if I see
upturns and things I will revise these
estimates yeah okay thank you any
further up cinema brought me this for
you Susan maybe Chris you were just
quoting some way she Chris will you pay
yep
what it was referring to as the total
revenue collected by the courts so if
you look at the document the summary
document you can see motor vehicle fines
is but in the middle of the page that's
their highway funds and then the other
piece that is different is the first row
penalty assessment that revenue goes
into the other category so when you're
looking at the courts revenue on your
estimate sheet it's starts with court
admin fees and goes to miscellaneous
sales revenue you back out the penalty
assessment and that's what I did on your
worksheet for you okay so then I guess
poor lunatic
all those things okay so it's not well
it's still considerably reduced 421
about 25 percent or so from 20 okay
so it'd be interesting to look looking
well go back and look at those for the
Great Recession see what that did
any further questions doesn't look like
Charlie Arling house and the I'm not
sure if the Comptroller is with us yes
you have lost charlie excuse me
commissioner Arleen house and a
controller they had to go to another
meeting okay there are specific
questions that the committee might have
I'm truly reached out and said they'd be
happy to address them if I sent an email
to him yeah does anybody have questions
about the other revenue sources I'm here
I'm trying to I can't show this thing it
if you have specific to what Treasury
does as it relates to other revenue yeah
Treasury is abandoned property only and
there was interest budgeted yes the
interest isn't so they could talk to
that mm-hmm
if they're still here okay yeah so
America is still still available good
afternoon madam chair and members of the
moon um Monica mr. Pelley Commissioner
of the Treasury and with me also as
Rachel Miller
chief deputy treasurer I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you well we
did have a considerable increase in in
the interest and surplus funds category
for this year and no projection at all
for 2021 yes so so as you as you hear up
there right now the interest rate
environment
has completely changed so the last years
we've been able to
earn some hard dollars harder learnings
with the interest rates that we're
increasing over time the last three to
four years through the judaculla
nineteen the Federal Reserve had to
react in and try to try to respond to
the crisis so they lower interest rates
from 0% to 0.25 percent so with that we
anticipate that the interest rate
environment will continue to be low and
there are other factors that we were
considering also we anticipate that with
the revenue decline that we we are
estimating our restricted cash balances
will also decline so with that we have
to look at different different different
ways that we've been doing maintaining
our cash balances we may need to go back
to what was done in 2008 2009 and years
after that try to maintain compensating
balances in order to defray the cost the
banking costs because those will remain
so knowing that interest rates are going
to remain low for some time well this
crisis it improves and again knowing
that our banking fees in cost will
remain pro the same so that would be one
way to try to mitigate those factors so
after looking at the ad in Oh again I
mean this situation is is uncertain
unclear how the revenues are going to
look you know maybe fiscal year twenty
bubi oki fiscal year twenty one I mean
you're looking at revenue estimates
right now depending of how that performs
there is a possibility we may need to
engage in short-term borrowing so that
really changes the picture of what we've
been doing and what we thought you know
a year a year ago you know to give you
some context the rates the Fed rates
last year were
[Music]
see right here we're 2.5% so now we're
talking about 0.5% so again there's
there's no interest right now in in the
dissipation of that being being there
for a while so those are the pieces
emeritus really rethink how we you know
we're estimating interest we decided to
eliminate it for fiscal year twenty one
so fiscal year twenty will be okay but
again it doesn't appear that we will
have interest for fiscal year twenty one
I remember there were a number maybe
four or five years that the treasurer
had no interest results at all after the
Great Recession started to take hold
exactly asking for several years that
was not estimated that was not
considered I think prior prior to 2008 I
think there was I think there were some
estimates being presented in the budget
but it's been it was several years that
that didn't occur until the budget for
fiscal year twenty twenty twenty-one
anyway we're back to where we were a few
used a few years back would you like to
see something also about the the
abandoned property I'm not sure how many
of the people on our committee realize
on what's entailed in this and why it
varies so much from year to year
yes and uh I I did I didn't provide any
detail because I wasn't sure you know
what type of questions that you will
have but you know as you may recall the
the treatment revenue it's really the
abandoned property that was reported to
us but we weren't able to return to the
rightful owner
so that property has been with us for
three years the law allows us to you
know what does not return
the law allows us to is Cheeta to
general fund so in that estimate we
there are several factors in that
formula we know how much was reported to
us three years ago we have to we have to
you know determine how many claims we've
paid against those those some those
properties the law also allows us to
deduct the Minnesota costs so we do that
and then after that is just our
calculation that we do in order to
determine what is is treated to the
counties and what can go to the general
fund a variable in that calculation that
is difficult to predict is the is the
property that gets reported to us in the
form of securities the castor was
reported does known we know exactly how
much that is what is unknown as the
security so before we use cheat the
revenue to the general fund we have to
liquidate positions we have to liquidate
securities and that is the securities I
get liquidated those go to the general
fund the hard part of this is that
obviously when we start doing this
process of liquidating the Securities we
start this process around March and then
we continue that process all the way
through before June so we are able to do
that calculation this year when we
started looking at the what was being
liquidated we stock market had a decline
of 20% we had those hard days in march
and fortunately the stock market every
recover somewhat but but we had to so
that's really the decline for this year
with what we were thinking and in in in
every year we is because that's a hard
number to predict what we do is we in
order to prepare an estimate we just
take a ten-year
average and we just put in the
calculation so the numbers that we put
in for fiscal year 20 and fiscal year 21
are based on the ten-year average that
we maintain but we don't know how the
stock market is going to be performing
at the time that we need to liquidate
those securities so this year we had a
little bit I'm gonna call it a loss but
I guess it wasn't spotted as it was in
previous years for example 2018-2019 we
had some good proceeds from those sales
unfortunately this year we had to you
know that wasn't as positive and and
that's why those numbers this year are
looking like that so we had them an
estimate of numbers when you have on
your sheet that was provided by the
controller we have we went down to a
point a million from 14 point 1 million
the the in for fiscal year 21 again we
just we just adjusted dot a little bit
so we kept it at 17 million seventeen
point three million just because again
we don't know how the stock market is
gonna be performing a year from now and
and we don't die in the market you know
our policy is not to try to predict a
market or anything like that again we
just we just follow policy we sell the
securities the time that we do it every
year and there's some good ears and
there others not so much
overall our goal is in our mission is to
return the funds to the rightful owner
but again since the law allows us to to
those funds that we weren't able to
return them we were able to escheat
include general funds so that's the
story there I don't know if you will you
have any additional questions related to
that
thank you I just like to say that if I
have a surface ten years later after you
you're the cheated and say hey that was
mine I believe that you pay it out of
the general fund through through
governor and council we do we do so the
law allows to return the funds anytime
even if it's been ten years like you
said so we we go we go to Governing
Council or request those funds and we
and we typically play those those those
funds to the rightful owner thank you
you're welcome
anything else you'd like to say about
this I think we covered everything
that's on this sheet thank you very much
Monica you too Chris I don't know if you
could help us with this there there seem
to be maybe six eight funds that were
among the bigger funds that they usually
analyze that have moved to restricted
funds by the budget are you talking
about the other funds the engineers
forms the electrician's boards the
permits so a number of funds that the
Joint Board or the what used to be the
Joint Board is names like Oh PLC used to
be generally funded and two sessions ago
it was the legislature decided to make
those are restricted fund so now all
that money goes directly to the fund
pays all the bills of the opt throughout
year which is where all the board's are
located now and then at the end of the
year they will lapse any surplus and
huh so it does lapse at some point but
safety managed to hold on to the
plumbers board somehow where there were
there were a couple of wards for
different reasons that didn't get
grouped under the O PLC I can't actually
speak to the reasons because I don't
know I'm not aware of what they are but
they're worse than that there was
decisions made not to group them right
okay so I think that we're suckers we
usually are in this in just accepting
the numbers that the Commissioner of das
comes up with or for other revenue
sources because one of them varies in
different directions for special reasons
and most of all me just so that to
remind the committee I mean the
Comptroller does work with the agencies
that collect that revenue to sort of you
know if there is an up or down related
to that so just the Comptroller you know
doing it all on her own with her staff
there is a some work done with the
agencies that are responsible for
collecting those revenue sources in that
other category yes okay so I guess I
hadn't asked that question since we got
a comptroller so you don't have several
agency people that are of questions you
might have
very glendan is there well Barry Glennon
whose names the Securities Bureau is
available from HHS if you want to talk
about Medicaid recoveries revenue and
then transportation is available if you
had any questions related to their they
have a small piece of the highway fund
yes about two hundred thousand dollars
but earlier there were questions about
traffic flow and and things like that
that application puts a lot of those
types of reports together
so I just want to let the committee know
we have still agency people that are
available that questions you might have
okay and we don't have anyone from the
Department of Justice about the tobacco
settlement not today no he did he did
submit a letter memo the that I see did
it doesn't talk about what seems to be
an apparent increase again in cigarettes
but we won't know for a while so it's
it's pretty proper than that he's not
speculating on it I guess
[Music]
they've had some delay in revenues
because of the kovat pandemic but they
expect to get to regular operations in
June and meet the plan and their
projections for the next year remain the
same I don't know if anyone wants to ask
about the likelihood that there will be
as many securities people out there when
we get through this as there are were in
January which I believe is what their
revenues are basically most of their
revenues are based on his securities
no questions we can go forward uh but
you're said representative of Romney has
a question absolutely bro me sure you
said there was no change and I'm looking
at a summary sheet and Felicia went down
securities went down two million their
projections from forty five to forty
three and a slight reduction about 1.3
million reduction for next year so if
that's different than what's on the
sheet you're looking at then the actual
numbers in one place there he can he can
respond to that yes are you there yes
serious our plan to the planet that came
from das now the plan of the plan that
was in the budget was for forty five
million in twenty and forty four point
three in twenty one and you're speaking
to another different plan which is for
forty three million into ID and forty
three million in twenty one looks like
we're having some issues with him being
able to speak but what I if I could dare
to speak based on the memory
the securities provided estimates to the
ways and means a year ago when you were
building the budget numbers were lower
than the numbers that were agreed to by
the legislature
I believe that's what he is basing his
estimate he says the estimate didn't
change yeah
originally provided the committee's
right not what the legislature finally
agreed to but so we can figure out how
to get him to speak yes I think he might
be able to now if you are you I'll stop
talking Barry can you hear me now
Christopher yes we can Barry
okay no reverberation or anything like
that nope okay great so I don't know if
you heard what I just said I was
basically suggesting you did hear okay
yes in fact that then that would account
for the difference the legislature had
put it in net around 45 our testimony
before which means has been consistent
protecting 43 3 3 but we have
experienced a slight reduction as
indicated in my mouth to representative
alley there is there has been some
impact with respect to phobic 19
pandemic delaying some of the agent
testing as well as a delay with regard
to some of the hardcopy mutual fund
filers which is really a significant
source but I'm still confident though
that if business resumes in June if New
York and Chicago and some of the major
cities and large farms open up coffee
filers performing in June when I say
performing I mean actually getting back
to business and forwarding those fees to
us that's been a major issue for a lot
of the firms that they have the ability
to work from home but to be able to
actually request checks and issue checks
has been an impediment for them so
that's why I'm hopeful that we will it's
projected
thank you this has been a problem with
it for a couple of agencies in a lot of
terms that the legislature does increase
the numbers at the last minute and those
are the ones that that were operating
off of and it's quite proper and I've
heard a number of other times very early
on you also have to to say okay go on
the official estimate which is the
budget estimate so yeah clear and I do
apologize no that's legislature that
any further questions on representative
rice thank you madam chair I it's not a
question pertaining to this I just need
to let you go I have to leave this
meeting because I have another meeting I
have to be on now okay okay but thank
you we're pretty close to the end anyway
okay thanks so much have a great day
everybody
you too so thanks represent follow me
Health and Human Services could talk to
recoveries but we didn't get anything
from recoveries except what you put in
the chart represent of all me yes I did
get an email from the fishing game
uh-huh
by 4 o'clock so I don't know if there's
any questions you have for them
yes there's one to the comment you were
just going to make yeah I would like to
so you have director Norman DOE and
Kathy Labonte right I think they may be
gather from looking at the report that
they sense that they have somewhere in
their revenues I guess in miscellaneous
sales and income they put the grants
that they get and they they've managed
to get two grants that show up in the
revenues football are remarkably healthy
for fishing game I don't understand
about the two grants do you hear me yes
well we did was we had a sale of one of
our properties mm-hmm that sale went
which went through long-range planning
and and G and C the the revenue from
that five hundred and five hundred and
thirty six thousand dollars is being
used to match a million dollar grant
from NOAA which means that grant which
is not represented and we have won that
grant to do a significant amount of work
on a large property we own on Great Bay
as part of the Great Bay research
reserve and we put it in a high light
because we had the we put the revenue
from that sale in that miscellaneous
sales and income line and wanted people
to understand what that large not was as
it is unusual so the revenue is in the
miscellaneous sales but the NOAA grant
and and park acquisition I guess and
doesn't show up acquisition well I'm
trying to remember the national estuary
and research reserve procurement
acquisition and construction I thought
it was for using the game farm for
something or other
we sold the game farm in Brentwood
thinking of funds that we got from that
sale for a major renovation project on a
piece in Greenland acres in here with
over three thousand be done you've got
the you've got the revenue in here a
surplus revenue but it's actually been
spent on something that is being spent
in the expenditure category well it
hasn't been spent yet it's just sitting
here penalty pending contracts and all
the other things that have to go on to
expend it but it is you're marked by us
for that project which is the only
reason why it went through long-range
planning and G and C because otherwise
we don't dispose the state properties
okay represented malooley has a question
the melanopsin malloy ab cinema why I'm
here yes thank you I just want to weigh
in on this this I've no comment about
the money here but I just want to say
that this is a huge deal the purchase of
this and vast improvement of an area
there's some work that's gonna need to
be done as we remediation but a great
great resource and I want to commend the
Fish and Game and everybody for weighing
in on this and making this happen this
is this is a terrific resource for the
Great Bay are pretty opens when we can
really get we went there I think the
public is just gonna eat it up it is
it's got a beautiful spot beautiful spot
thank you the other page why why would
underfunded road tolls for off-highway
vehicles and marine next year because
we're we looked at them and in in recent
years those numbers represent what we've
been getting
here is the 700 and 800 based on
long-term averages but over the last
couple years with more boats and more
especially Morro HRVs
revenues have consistently been in the
range that we're projecting here
and so we've met we're maintained
we're just bringing we're bringing
projection in line with what history is
saying is going on you have increases
next year in this year too so what is it
what's the static property Sandy Point
yeah every Center no the the Greenland
property is just up the up the shoreline
from the Portsmouth country okay but in
terms of the licenses looks like you're
projecting pretty much what you had
projected Manny's right uptick yeah well
you know if we have hopes that the
licenses will be up going 21 however you
know we're in this very special
circumstance right here where we've had
really huge increases in our fishing
licenses which is you know not to be
unexpected when you look at nobody could
even go out and play baseball but they
could still go fishing so all of the
normal spring sport stuff is pretty much
shut down but people could still go
fishing and they are going fishing so
we're happy to
to take those fees and I certainly hope
that if some people maybe have come back
into it they will continue but I would
not bet the house on the fact that it
will be the same way next spring when
potentially all the normal activities
back and play fishing license have a
notoriously high wash factor or often
people will buy them you know two out of
every five years or whatever there's
there's less consistency with the same
person always buying fishing licenses
overall so you know we we're optimistic
but you know we really don't want to
extrapolate the conditions were in right
now to the too far into the future thank
you
right the world
they probably hope our fishing license
sales go down because that may mean
we're getting so which spring turkey
hunting really may we had record turkey
license sales also great okay so so
you'd like this to continue until the
deer season well actually we have a
little problem in that well that would
be great we're also being stymied in our
hunter ed classes because of all of the
restrictions and whatnot so we have a
backlog of of folks want hunter ed
certification and we really have not got
a great way to to deal with it so they
can they can take the program
on line but they still need to do a
field a day of field activity and we're
hoping to be able to accommodate with a
with a full-out effort in August but we
probably are still going to be highly
limited in the number of people per
class that we can happen in play so I'm
not sure they'll probably be some
constituent unhappiness as that plays
out but absent some changes in the in
the numbers allowed for gathering at all
thank you well I think that that looks
pretty good for you this year yeah we're
we're lucky right okay thank you thank
you we have two other small pieces on
Department of Health and Human Services
apparently she's been waiting around to
talk to us about Medicaid recoveries
which was available for questions if you
had available for questions right and if
karen downes um who's available to talk
to you well is everybody okay the
estimate for Medicaid recoveries you're
recovering from the estates of people
mostly and at this particular time there
is likely to be less money out there to
recover I don't know if that's a good
way of synthesizing that one but but
maybe we could go on
the Department of Transportation which I
don't think sent us anything except the
numbers that you have in here for
miscellaneous in the highway fund so I
had emailed Murray Mullin and she
confirmed there was no changes mm-hmm
she provided was just the turnpike
report that was also again sent you huh
I don't think I saw it turnpike record
but we don't get to do the Turnpike's
anyway so it was a traffic report I
think there was the flow of traffic and
what's been happening with the kovat and
stay home orders everybody yesterday in
case they wanted to see every week now
coming up for closer to normal traffic
it's still going to take us a while but
lost 2 to 35% 38% this last week yes the
repo is on Turnpike tolls which of
course is not all of African state right
this is Murray Mullin from New Hampshire
Department of Transportation and yeah we
we had a high of about a 57 percent
decline in mid-april and as of Sunday
that decline was at 38 percent so we
have been gradually seeing some traffic
coming back but we still are seeing
significant declines over FY 19 over
last year and you know we're going now
into the summer season and that's where
our transactions are highest so you know
we're still anticipating that we're
going to see significant declines
over these next several months depending
how things open up and whether folks can
actually stay and and come into the
state right it'll be interesting to see
what the Memorial Day weekend looks like
well that's through Sunday it was a 38
percent decline so that would have been
Friday Saturday Sunday mm-hmm so it did
not include Monday but through Sunday
there was a 38 percent so that's why the
week before I think was around 43
percent so we did see some traffic
increase over that week with the holiday
weekend but we are still seeing large
declines in the transactions coming
through the tolls yes okay are we still
Manning on totals
yes we well we meters we are Manning the
the toll booths and the centers we are
doing cash collections we are doing
change now at one point we had stopped
doing change we were doing exact change
only to try to limit the touch points
what for our for the customers and for
our total attendance but we are doing
change again and we do have all the cash
lanes open that that are needed we did
reduce the third shift so we went down
due to the significant decrease in
traffic we did go down to two shifts we
had during the day between 5:00 a.m. and
9:00 p.m. and we have not been staffing
during the evening hours because the
traffic had been so low and we were
actually spending more on total
attendance than we were collecting in
revenue so we had made that decision
back at the end of March to to move to
two shifts to try to save some some
money and for the safety but those folks
that go through go through the back
office system and have you know the
license they get billed or they can do
the seven data
hey go online and do the seven-day to
pay so we're still collecting and going
after that that that revenue for those
folks that were going through late in
the evening thank you
any further questions for the
transportation department about the
revenues and I think I think that takes
care of that thank you for waiting so
long marine I hope you've been doing
something else in the meantime other
agencies too huh
okay so I think that wraps up everything
that that we had in front of us for
those of us that are still awake right
now I can see a few people nodding a
little bit but we're going to the
Republicans I think are gonna hold a
caucus tomorrow representing major is
muted at the moment there is yes and
we're holding one Friday afternoon which
gives us a chance to go and look at all
these numbers and at the numbers that
we've done before and trying to figure
out where we are
I don't know at this point if we're
going to end up with a single estimate
for those taxes or arrange but I think
the committee's right that we ought to
to see if we feel more comfortable with
some kind of range even for for this
and then um absent major it sounded like
you were trying to say something yes
that was a question I have for you that
we went through this today and just
about everybody it was a number rather
than a range yes range
yes what is your plan for money well it
depends on what we come back with from
our two caucuses and I think you and I
need to get together this weekend and/or
send each other an email yeah and see
where we are on these things a single
number seems pretty difficult at this
point a single number for 2020 Bobby
it's something we could attempt right
the trouble is the business taxes and
they IND Texas we really don't know how
yeah I is there anyone else who wants to
horn in on this before we well I'm sorry
I said Patrick when his hand up he did
yeah I just wanted to chime in I do
think that for fiscal year 21 we should
do a range and I'm not sure exactly how
we do that but and also I think
truth is for this fiscal year even
though we're is very close to the end
we've got two accounts that are it could
come in very different ways and we just
we don't know and to pretend that we do
know with a single number I'm
uncomfortable so I'd prefer to even it
was just a variant from the norm that
the DRA has given us say plus or minus
10 percent I don't know I'm just
throwing that out in some way of
for the business taxes and interesting
dividends especially since it's been
on that yeah it is also true that in
fiscal year 21 there are a number of
lines that are basically a single number
of lines I think we don't have any extra
information on most of them yeah
probably not their intent to being to
revise them later yeah yeah Sam I wonder
if we could just ask Chris Shea on
particularly interest in dividends and
and the business taxes when they if if
the biggest businesses for instance do
as the DRA was saying and wait until
they have finished their their federal
returns which will be July 15th and then
start giving it up on my mistakes we
will see that money in late to life
we're lucky and probably in August
and they will what they they they
capture that for the kaffir so it never
shows up in the 21 money and it hasn't
gotten into the 20 money so from our
perspective it's just disappeared so
commissioner Steph had mentioned that
there's a 60-day window once the year
closes that they'll look at the revenues
come in to determine should they have
been credited to just ended or is it
okay to stay at the current fiscal year
that they're in so you're correct you're
wouldn't see it in your June reports you
would just see it reflected in the
kafir' if there was more revenue you'd
see an increase in the business taxes
once the kafir' you know and once it
went through the audit and now all the
eyes are crossed
but you wouldn't wouldn't be reflected
in your other revenue focus the
preliminary cash base for the
preliminary unaudited wouldn't
necessarily reflect that and it won't
show up in August either in the month
would be they would make an adjustment
for it once they believe it's recognized
for the prior year so you shouldn't see
it in here Frank so maybe we ought to
handle that with some kind of footnote
in our estimate that we believe that
there's another 18 million million call
it coming in July or August which
belongs to June and which will not be
seen again except in the cavern what I
mean I think what I took from today's
conversation from dra is that they
really need to see June come to an end
to see how the behavior of the the
companies and taxpayer kind of seeing
for the month you think if there's 18 of
money that people pushed out to June
when they probably shouldn't have
are they going to pay that was one of
the questions and if they pay there's
gonna be some penalty and interest
associated with that when the auditors
get done with them
other factors related to federal return
and and the big companies deciding is it
better to you know New Hampshire as a
smaller state and say okay I'm willing
to pay penalties and interest on what I
might not paid in order to pay for a
larger company I see a larger state and
a way bigger penalty and interest and
those are all behavior nobody can really
predict it this time I don't know if you
need a nobody to miss because you it's
done the conversations I've had with you
is that you and your committee looking
at fiscal 21 pretty regularly throughout
the upcoming year
so you would get a sense in the next
time you get some information from DRA
what actually occurred and if you then
need to make a note that might be that's
time to do it I don't remember that
we've ever even gotten that information
except maybe two years later when we
were talking about previous pay
performance but they did say that these
larger companies seem to be waiting
until they had finished their federal
returns and they're gonna finish their
so anyway the best guess I think it's
best guess I don't know if you need to
put a note like three numbers that have
questions though yeah yes we've got
three members of questions or comments
representing but Brahmi okay I have a
larger question I mean what's the
pressure on us to do 21 estimates now
and not wait until after June for a
number and there's also the question of
whether now that's that's for 2020
looking for a number at some point I
would say by August we're going to have
to try to do something serious about 20
20 21 because there are many I mean
depending on on what happens if the
governor maintains control of everything
until I've until the election and after
then on we can't do a supplemental
budget but we did two supplemental
budgets in the Great Recession
readjusting things and programming out
where the spending had to be cut and how
much spending had to be cut for that was
September we get upset if it's going to
be a question of going going worse
rather than going better the more cuts
have to be made so we have no choice but
to arrange them because as many there's
20 of us in this committee and there's
probably 20 opinions as to how quickly
things are going to open up new strains
are not really affected at all if you
look at the main ones they're influenced
by different things I could see on
Monday or even so caucuses the battle
being a man this discussion is it a V is
it a V and not a V what's going to be
that will really dictate the revenue so
I could see in my mind the high estimate
is is based on
quick opening and hello estimates based
on a on a slow opening so I guess that's
what I think it is on this and others
might be affected but in a very
different way
absolutely so it's discussions if we all
know there was a vaccine Southworth had
his hand up thank you and I suggest I
think it would save a lot of I think it
would save a lot of time on Monday if
you already come in with a range that we
could play with rather than starting at
zero because we're it's not gonna be way
off from the agency s cool just to have
a starting range I think would save a
lot of time maybe after to caucus a
couple of you could talk but just that
be a big time-saver and maybe even the
range could be on our sheet or we can
put on our sheet because if we start at
zero it's gonna go around and around
yeah I think could could do that that
would help everyone I think it's okay
and Jenny you had your hand up um
Patrick asked my question like oh yeah
okay on us to get it done for 2021 I
knew I should have started with the
person who hadn't asked many questions
yet okay so we're all set into our
caucuses and then Monday right and the
Democratic one it's gonna start at one I
don't have the confirmation yet cuz
I haven't looked at my email all day
from Dan if it's going to come from him
or not if not I think Jerry had
suggested that he could fill in so so
that's know so you'll get something from
one or the other
you need only co-host help because I got
to step out well I'm sort of getting I
got something else from Dan you don't
know how many you're the credit details
they're even born doesn't know how the
very your kind of details there are
mixed into trying to do this stuff
virtually where you go bucs that's why
you get the big bucks 25 bucks make sure
you push your button see you get your
mileage to give a smiling we haven't
heard about that yeah okay so we're all